Welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof.
Hello Walter.
Hi Martin, I see you have the same
writing on your chest again. Is it Yes,
I put it on so that you can maybe just
clarify what's on it. What does it say?
Outdoor garment. Yes. Now that makes no
sense. Why are you wearing it when
you're indoors?
I think the climate change indoors has
caused it.
That I have to put it on. All right,
okay. That's a reasonable explanation.
Maybe it can convince the nation.
Let's open with a word of prayer.
Then we can start. Our heavenly father,
thank you again for bringing us
together.
And
we want to discuss some important things
again. So we ask that you will you bless
the discussion. Enlighten our minds with
Holy Spirit. In Jesus name, amen. Amen.
Now Martin,
there are certain things that have to
fall into place in order for the
complete prophetic picture
to reach the climax that
is predicted in the Bible, right?
So you have to have certain
environmental issues that have to
take place.
You have to have
ethnic problems, nation against nation,
ethnos against ethnos, kingdom against
kingdom.
You have to have the political aspects
of the healing of the wound. In other
words, the political power has to be
uh given back to the first beast. Its
influence in politic in the political
sphere has to be restored. You have to
have the religious aspects, the children
must return to the mother. Mhm.
Mhm. That's in the
So churches. I will not suffer loss of
children. So the Protestant churches
must return to the mother.
This church must have a universal clout
also with other religions
because the Bible says everything
revolves around her.
And we see that happening in the world.
Then you have to have the implementation
of the mark of the beast. Plus you must
have all the legislation in place in
order to implement it also in terms of
buying and selling. And all of that has
to come together
at exactly the same time. They must all
be in place. Mhm.
Now prophetically
to put all of those into place and into
position
at exactly the same time
is beyond chance.
It is definitely a fulfillment of
prophecy if all of those things fall
into place.
Now last time we spoke about the climate
agenda
and how the climate agenda can be used
in order to implement the mark of the
beast.
Yes.
And the beast will tell you us what its
mark is. It is Sunday as the mark of
authority of the first beast.
And when Protestantism acknowledges that
authority and obeys that decree and
makes it a law
then it has created an image to the
beast.
And we have to now look at the second
component, the implementation of the
buying and selling issue.
Are the necessary legal systems in place
so that that can take place, so that
everything can culminate at exactly the
same time? Yeah.
And once it's all there
isn't that an indication that it's over?
That's it.
It's so beautiful
that that acknowledges 100% that the
Bible is true. Yes. Because now like you
just mentioned earlier there's no other
predictions or anything
that has a chance of getting together
like that. In that fashion. It's like
It's like the identification of the
first beast.
The little horn of Daniel.
God made sure that there are so many
criteria that are mentioned Yeah.
that have to all culminate in one
organization
so that statistically it's impossible
for that to happen unless it is true.
Yeah.
So all those those criteria that you
have, all those identifying features in
Daniel chapter 7 of the little horn
which again are given in a synopsis form
in Revelation chapter 13
linking the beast out of the sea with
the little horn power of Daniel chapter
7. And that prophetic picture and that
profile is so clear Mhm.
that all the reformers unanimously
identified Rome as the little horn
power.
And all the children of the reformed
churches deny that fact because they
don't study the prophecies anymore
other than through the lens of Jesuit
theology, which is a counter reformation
theology. That is the most horrendous
thing that has ever happened to
Christianity since its inception.
You see the problem is the devil is
cunning.
And that's why he has all his bases
covered.
He infiltrated and along with it there's
physical persecution.
But humanity will be without excuse. Oh
yeah. Because it was clearly
shown who's who in the zoo.
And it was done biblically.
Today
the Bible
is there
and people love to quote the Bible
but the essence of what it says is
totally ignored. That's so true.
So let's go to our topic which is
digital money, worldwide digital ID to
control humanity in the issue of buying
and selling.
And let us go to the prophetic picture
and he had power to give life unto the
image of the beast. So
the image of the beast, the second beast
of Revelation chapter 13 will receive
that power.
And it will make an image. In other
words, church and state will unite. It
is not a question of if, it is a
question of when. Yeah.
That the image of the beast should both
speak
and cause. That means it has legislative
power. It can make laws, it can speak
and it can enforce, Mhm. cause.
That as many as would not worship the
image of the beast should be killed.
Now
worship the image of the beast. In other
words, worship this politico-religious
system.
How do you worship it? By obeying it.
That's it.
But because it's worship
it means that it must have a very
particular religious connotation
and obedience contrary to God's will.
Yeah.
There's no other way.
You either worship God, worship
God.
Revelation chapter first 14, worship him
who made the heavens, the earth, the sea
and the springs of water. And the sign
of that was the Sabbath. Yeah.
Here is the one who says, "No, I have a
new gospel for you." The first beast.
You will be saved through my sacramental
system. That's what Martin Luther
already said. Mhm. The Roman Catholic
Church has deceived the world through
its theology and sacramental system
which has taken the place
of the word of God. Right. And has taken
the place of justification by faith.
So
when you worship the image of the beast
then you are obeying this image of the
beast, this church and state
conglomerate that is acting in the same
way as the church of the Middle Ages
acted.
When you worship it, you are doing this
contrary to God's will.
So, it must be associated with something
that has to do with God's will and
acknowledgement of his authority.
And he causes all, both small and great,
rich and poor, free and bond, to receive
a mark in their right hand or in their
forehead.
Now, the word in is very important. It's
not on.
In other words, it is a cognitive
action. Correct. And this also then
brings in the portion if you are not
completely doing it out of religious
conviction. Then you are doing it
because you're being caused, you're
being forced.
So, it's either an act of obedience,
whether you agree or not, or it is an
act of conformity because you agree.
And that no man might buy or sell, save
he that had the mark or the name of the
beast or the number of his name.
Now, the name of the beast is his
character. In other words, you admire
him.
You are doing what he says because you
think he's right.
Or the number of his name, and his
number is 666 as we will as we all know.
And that is the worldly number.
It is not the heavenly number. It is
doing man's will and not God's will.
And man's will is dictated not by man,
but by the dragon.
So, Martin, it is important that the
government has legislation in place
in order to implement the rules
regarding buying and selling. Okay. Now,
we've shown this before,
but for the sake of completeness, let's
show it again.
What underpins a world order is always
the financial system. And what we're
seeing in the world today, I think, is
we are on the brink of a dramatic change
where we are about to, and I'll say this
boldly,
we're about to abandon the traditional
system of money and accounting
and introduce a new one.
And the new one, the new accounting, is
what we call blockchain. It means
digital. It means having a almost
perfect record of every single
transaction that happens in the economy,
which will give us far greater clarity
over what's going on. It also raises
huge dangers in terms of the balance of
power between states and citizens. In my
opinion, we're going to need a digital
constitution of human rights if we're
going to have digital money. Uh but also
this new money will be sovereign in
nature. Most people think that digital
money is crypto and private. But I what
I see are superpowers introducing
digital currency. The Chinese were the
first.
The US is on the brink, I think, of
moving in the same direction. The
Europeans have committed to that as
well. And the question is, will that new
system of digital money and digital
accounting accommodate the competing
needs of the citizens of all these
locations so that every human being has
a chance to have a better life? Cuz
that's the only measure of whether a
world order really serves.
So, now is the time to think through how
will we solve this?
And that will be part of the answer of
what will the new order work like.
Martin,
so they will have to put in a system
because they will know about every
single transaction.
But they will also be able to control
Yes. every single transaction. We've
shown previously that, for instance, if
you get government money, or they can
even
dictate to you of your own money what
you can spend it on. Correct.
Or whether you can spend it at all.
Exactly.
So, here's the Deutsche Wirtschafts
Nachrichten,
the German Economic News.
Tower of Babel, the Great Depression 2
will trigger the world's greatest
financial catastrophe.
The world is reportedly heading for a
second edition of the Great Depression.
But the coming financial crash will
surpass anything we have seen in human
history.
The introduction of a separate banking
system was a reaction by the US
government to a serious financial crisis
in the year 1929 to 1933.
The high losses for general public, of
which were not least possible because
banks had carried out both classic
customer business and speculation.
The 2008 crash was actually a mini
crash. No correction has ever taken
place. Instead, it was papered over by a
massive increase in debt, ensuring that
when the inevitable big crash did occur,
the severity would be far beyond any
other crash in history. When the
expected crash will occur remains
uncertain.
It is certain that it will happen.
So, there is going to come a great
reset, Yeah.
whether we like it or not. I think
they're already
busy with it.
So, some people say, "Whatever you need,
get it now."
So, are the countries falling into line?
Jerusalem Post. Israel bans the use of
cash for purchases larger than NIS
6,000.
So, cash deals exceeding the 6,000 will
be illegal as part of the effort to
fight against money laundering and
criminal activity.
Mhm. So, again, you will be curtailed.
And their reason
might seem plausible, but I don't think
that's a real reason.
No, of course not. The real reason is
control. Yeah.
Absolute control. So, under the new law,
any payment to a business above this
particular amount
must be made using alternative methods,
such as digital transfer or debit card.
Trading between private citizens who are
not listed as business owners will be
limited to 15,000
NIS, which is about $4,360
in cash.
So, they're going to limit you.
Can they limit you totally if they want
to? Yes, for sure.
And maybe it's important just to note or
mention that
like you said before, the way to not be
part of this in the end will be to
look after yourself. Yes. But there's no
way that you will not be sucked into
this system. Now, Martin, particularly
if you are dependent on all the
organizations around you. So, if you're
a city dweller,
you will be dependent
on things like supermarkets and
everything else that
revolves around life in the city.
You won't be able to grow your own food,
etc.
So, all of these issues are coming to a
head.
There's another article in The Guardian,
also from 2022. So, just to show that
these things are actually happening, and
they're happening now.
UK cashless society a step closer as
more than 23 million people abandon
coins.
Well, it's been a long time coming, but
coins really have virtually no value
anymore anyway. Yeah. They've devalued
the it so much that you only have
worthless money paper money, actually.
Correct. So, whenever I get change,
I put it into
a little spot, and I use it for handouts
when people do things like you for you,
like wash your windscreen or or
whatever.
So, this is already happening.
So, they expect that coins will account
for just 6% of payments within a decade.
So, basically, we don't have to read it
all, but we are going towards a cashless
society.
That's the bottom line.
Here again is the Deutsche Wirtschafts
Nachrichten. Frozen balances in China
lead to bank runs and protests.
So, people don't have access to their
money. So, this created quite a stir,
riots, and even hold-ups in order to get
their money back, right?
First, losing the job due to China's
zero COVID policy,
then get the money you saved for life
frozen without giving you a reason,
finally, being prevented from
demonstrating by means of a Corona QR
code.
So, you are totally hedged in. You
cannot even move.
That's it. They've
brought together all the coercion
methods there. Yes. And And because
there's such a housing shortage in
China,
people buy houses that aren't built yet,
and then the companies that are supposed
to build them go bankrupt. And then the
people have spent a lot of money on
something they don't even get.
And many other cases, many of these
apartments were actually built, and then
they were imploded again.
But you've put your money in there. So,
this must create quite a bit of anger in
some of the people.
So,
this is a wrecking reality for hundreds
of thousands of Chinese for months.
On the one hand, financial experts are
warning of the consequences of the Henan
banking crisis for the global economy.
She has already reacted sensitively to a
radical China's lockdown policy.
On the other hand, the incidents
surrounding the suddenly invalid Corona
QR codes of Chinese citizens illustrate
how vulnerable digital systems for
individual health certification are to
political abuse of power. We must never
forget
that the beast
also is a copy of the true.
Yeah.
Right? It is a counterfeit.
And therefore, as we have said all
along, it also has a right arm. Yeah. It
has a gospel. It's not the gospel of the
Bible
because Rome doesn't believe in the
atonement.
Yeah.
So, it's not the gospel of the Bible.
It's not about righteousness by faith
because Rome does not believe in
righteousness by faith.
And it has a right arm. It has a health
message, but it is the health message of
Asclepius.
Mhm.
So, you need a digital ID
QR code. You need to be locked into
their system on every single level.
Now, what are people afraid of, Martin?
Well. Aren't they afraid of hunger?
Yes. So, food is a very important thing
that you need.
You need housing.
Yeah. You need a roof over your head.
And you need health care.
That's it.
And if those things are not in place,
then people become panicking.
All right?
Now, there is a health system that God
gives and there's a health system that
the world gives.
And we know that the worldly one is
securely
anchored
in the Roman system.
And we will in a future episode look at
that again.
And just to remind the people that all
of these things that we have been
experiencing over the last 2 years are
anchored in
Jesuitism. Yes.
For example, the founders of the medical
system that we have are based on
Jesuitism.
So, let's have a look at this crisis in
China. Which is of course just a symptom
for the rest of the world as well.
Weaker protest in China crushed by
officials. Who are the protesters?
People who had lost their life savings.
China's banks are going through a major
crisis and these are people from the
Henan province. In the month of April,
four banks in Henan stopped withdrawals.
Meaning, people who had deposited money
in these banks could not withdraw.
The people struggled for months. They
protested at least twice and every time
the Chinese state responded with a
fierce crackdown.
Look at this headline. China mortgage
boycott data erased by censors as crisis
spreads. The story broke today.
And when Chinese censors swing into
action,
it is often an indication that there is
a big problem. According to one report,
the boycott is happening in as many as
86 cities.
How many projects? More than 230.
How much money are we talking about? At
least 58 billion dollars. That's the
value of all the loans in delayed
housing projects.
How will China revive these projects?
Its options are limited. China's
property sector has become one of its
biggest liabilities. Recent defaults
have put banks at risk. The actual debt
pile is much bigger. Again, I have some
numbers. Chinese banks have lent 9.2
trillion dollars to the property sector.
And more than half of these are mortgage
loans.
We've seen all of this before.
This is exactly what happened in the
year 2008, the subprime mortgage crisis
in America. That's what it was. The
bigger problem is the fact that China is
trying to hide all of it.
The world needs to know about China's
bad loans. In 2020, it hid the spread of
the Wuhan virus and the world got a
pandemic.
In 2022, China's hiding another crisis
that could give us a financial pandemic.
Okay, Martin. So, we're always looking
at it from the prophetic point of view,
right?
So, there must be a mechanism put in
place to control how people spend money.
That's a new system.
That is. It didn't exist before.
No, because you have money, but you
cannot spend it. So, does it curtail
your activities?
100%.
And can it direct your activities in a
particular direction? Is that what the
Bible says will happen? Exactly. We're
looking at prophecy, right?
Is it coupled to the mark? Yes.
It's coupled to the mark because buying
and selling and the mark of the beast
are inseparable in the Bible.
So, if it is coupled to the mark, how
are the countries
faring in the implementation? Let's have
a look.
So, Euronews tells us about a four-day
week.
Which countries have embraced it and
how's it going so far? The idea is
simple.
Employees would work four days a week
while getting paid the same and earning
the same benefits, but with the same
workload.
Hailed as the future of employee
productivity and work-life balance,
advocates for the four-day workweek
suggest that when implemented, worker
satisfaction increases and so does
productivity.
Trade unions across Europe are calling
for governments to implement the
four-day working week, but which
countries have embraced the idea and
how's it going so far?
Belgium to introduce a four-day workweek
for employees who want it. UK kicks off
a six-month trial in June. Scotland and
Wales join the growing global movement.
Iceland, one of the leaders in the
four-day working week. Sweden mixed
reactions to the four-day week. German
startup experiments
the shorter workweek. Japan big corps
venture into the four-day workweek.
Spain to start a trial phase.
Unilever currently
trialing the shorter workweek in New
Zealand and stronger interests in the US
and Canada. So, it looks like a
universal movement.
Mhm.
So, what is the
what is the actual outcome if this will
happen?
Well, one of the days that will be free
is what? Sunday. Sunday.
All right, here's Business Techs. South
Africa will need to change laws to
introduce a four-day workweek.
While a growing number of companies in
South Africa and around the world are
considering the adoption of a four-day
workweek,
the country's labor laws will likely
need amending to permanently accommodate
such a shift.
So,
they're talking about the increased
morale of the employees.
But everywhere else when it comes to the
Sunday issue,
this is one of the issues.
So, isn't this a nice way
to create ground for it? That's what I
Let's Let's make a little more space,
but let's have Sunday in there. Yeah,
that's what I want to say. This is maybe
just a forerunner for something that
they want to implement.
Now, of course, we also need to have the
technology in place
to monitor what you
are doing in your little neck of the
woods
and what I am doing and what everybody
else is doing.
And then in that digital profile, you
must have all the information that is
available on that particular individual.
Now, when you go into an app in in the
days that we are living in,
and they ask you, "What is your name?"
And you put your name into that little
thing over there, then immediately pops
up not only your name, but your ID
number, your social security number,
your telephone number, your domicile,
where you are living, what your address
is, what your physical address is.
Do they have the data as to what
religion you belong to?
Now, a few years ago, they had a census
in South Africa
and everybody had to take part in the
census.
So, they came to my house and they asked
me
to fill in the census form, which I did.
And there was a category at the bottom
which said religion. What religion do
you belong to? So, I put Christian.
Okay.
Then they came back to me and said,
"Excuse me, you can't say Christian.
You have to say what denomination you
belong to."
I said, "Why must I give my
denomination? What has that got to do
with you, what denomination I belong
to?"
And in any case, people change
denominations like shirts these days.
Not that I will, but uh
just for interest's sake, I asked them,
"Why should I put in that?"
And they said it is required.
So, I said, "Okay. Now, what do you do
in the case of Muslims? What does it say
there?"
Religion, it says Muslim.
I said, "But that's not fair. Is it a
Shiite Muslim or is it a Sunni Muslim?
Surely it should say what denomination
he belongs to. And if he doesn't have
to, then neither do I."
They were very upset with me and they
said that they would take further
action.
Uh to date, they have not.
But the the further action is actually
quite unnecessary because they know what
denomination you are of anyway.
Exactly. Now,
it You're ignorant if you think that you
can hide even if you live remotely,
don't think that they don't know where
you are. They they know. You know what?
I've often been asked this question.
They know. So, what point is what point
is there in doing this?
I always say to myself and to others,
you know what? When the real trouble
begins,
it'll be a time of trouble such as never
was.
They might be so busy
that it'll take them a while to get to
you.
Particularly if you're out of the way
and it's a problem.
Exactly. And there is God that can hide
you in the cleft of the rock. I was
living on this farm
remotely.
And we had a farm in the Cape.
And we were driving to the airport. I
was going to fly away that day. So, we
drove
quite a few kilometers, well over 200
kilometers.
And I drove all along the back of the
mountain through this area.
And we saw a fire,
a mountain fire. Now, the thing to do in
that area if you say have a fire, you're
supposed to report it.
So, we got to the next town, which was
about
150 odd kilometers from where I lived.
And we walked in and we said, "We just
want to report that we saw a fire."
And they said, "Okay.
What is your name?" And we gave our name
and
just like that, they told me
where I lived, Yeah. everything about
me. I thought, "How did these people
know?" A tiny little police station
somewhere in the middle of nowhere and
they knew all of these things. Of
course. I mean, we've got a
company called TransUnion in South
Africa and there's It's We've mentioned
this before, but that's got all your
digital now that digital information.
That's linked to the government, to
banks, to you know, the receiver of
revenue, all of this. So, the police.
So, even for if you don't have a
smartphone or for that matter
a technological device, your data is
already there.
Correct. It's already there. Now, how
serious are they about
making sure that you are on this
database?
Now,
this particular gentleman, in my
opinion, uh
on many occasion deems himself more
intelligent than God.
Mhm. But that's his problem. We'll
listen to what he has to say anyway.
Very soon people will walk around with
biometric sensors on or even inside
their bodies and will allow Google or
Facebook or the Chinese government or
whoever to constantly monitor what's
happening inside my body.
The whole idea that humans have, you
know, this they they have this soul or
spirit and they have free will and
nobody knows what's happening inside me.
So, whatever I choose, whether in the
election or whether in the supermarket,
this is my free will. That's over. We
have the technology to hack human beings
on a massive scale. New surveillance
technologies that are now deployed just
to deal with this coronavirus outbreak,
when it's over, some governments may
say, "Yes, but there is a second wave of
corona coming. So, we have to be
prepared. And there is Ebola and there
is also regular flu. Why not protect
people against that, too, with this new
surveillance system?" So, the tendency
would be to prolong it indefinitely.
Also, it's the moment when surveillance
goes really under the skin.
Governments are now not not just
interested in where we go and who we
meet, but even in what's happening
inside our bodies.
The point is they have the technology.
And they can introduce it through a
forced program.
And if you do not take part in the
forced program, well, then they you are
economically isolated. Buying and
selling.
Is it in place? That is the question.
That's
It's definitely Is it important in terms
of the biblical prophecy?
Mhm.
But maybe somebody will ask us now, "So,
what do we do about this?"
Well, Martin, what do you suggest you do
about it?
I think adhere to what the spirit of
prophecy says in the Bible. Okay. As far
as you can, look after yourself, get out
of the cities,
look after yourself, and leave the
consequences to God. Leave That is an
important point. That's the bottom line.
Leave the consequences to God.
Yes, they will be able to find you. Yes,
they will be able to do all of those
things,
but you have a protector that they know
nothing about.
That's
And you leave those consequences to God.
Do what is right.
Leave the consequences to God. So,
actually, it's a call from God to get
your faith and your introspection in
such and your relationship with him in
such a better state. Hebrews chapter 11,
without faith, it is impossible
to please him.
I think it's verse 6, chapter 11.
National Fuel Pass QR Program
Island-wide implementation from the 25th
of July.
This is 2022.
Colombo, the National Fuel Pass QR
system will be implemented across the
island from Monday, the 25th of July,
tweeted the minister responsible for
this action.
So, a national fuel pass. So, it's just
to show again, they will control every
aspect of your life. What you can and
what you cannot. What you can do and
what you cannot do.
So, again, get your ducks in a row.
Do what you can. Hezekiah
prepared
for the siege.
And he diverted the water. And he took
care of many many things. And then he
left the consequences to God. But he had
to do something. That's very important.
You always have to put your foot in the
Jordan before the waters recede.
WFP and the Iraqi Ministry of Trade
launch a food ration smartphone app for
1.6 million people in Iraq.
The United Nations World Food Program
and Iraqi Minister of Trade launched the
Tamwini, My Food Ration smartphone
application in Najaf,
which will roll out for 1.6 million
across the governorate. A robust public
distribution system that is constantly
updated in real time
will also allow for the prioritization
of the most vulnerable families. Under
this social protection program, the PDS
digitalization is also providing the
foundation for other government
ministries to align and create one
single social register
of families most in need of support.
They always have this little cherry.
It's always for the good of someone.
But actually, it's all about control.
It's so sad because they play
the religious look after your neighbor.
And then they come but they've got the
hidden plan as well.
The Financial Times. This is all from
2022.
Iran's Raisi cuts back on bread
subsidies.
So, the Iranian president has announced
plans to cut back bread subsidies as
wheat prices soar globally
and Iran tries to steer the economy hard
hit by US sanction on oil exports. The
government will offer citizens digital
coupons
that will allow them to access a limited
amount of bread as subsidized prices,
while the rest will be available at
market rates.
Would it be then easily possible to
shift to total control?
Definitely. It's already there. It's
just punching in a number.
Yeah.
Fighting cash, Australia tests digital
currency.
The Central Bank is thus following a
call from the Bank for International
Settlements to all the world's leading
central banks to prepare for the
introduction of digital currencies.
To how many banks? All.
All? In addition to Australia, the US,
the EU, China also pushing ahead with
the abolition of cash.
110 countries around the world are
currently preparing to introduce digital
currencies. The question is, is the
system in place?
You're going to be very surprised if
you're still ignorant of it.
Okay.
So, the US Federal Reserve is already
working flat out on the development of a
digital dollar,
and the work is already well advanced as
recently published documents show. In
fact, President Biden
signed a document which implements this
very thing.
There's another article. Newest Digital
Identity Act expected to pass, paving
the way for the next generation ID.
Martin,
Bible prophecy is fulfilling before our
eyes. Not that this means of accessing
your money is the mark of the beast.
No.
God is not concerned, as I've said a
thousand times already, as to what you
spend your money on or how you spend it
or what means you use to pay.
He's interested in your character.
He's interested to know what is going on
in your mind. Who do you acknowledge
as your God?
A new US digital identity bill is
steadily making its way through
Congress. Martin, why now?
Why all the countries doing it now?
Because the final movements will be
rapid ones. They know exactly what is
coming. They've been prepared.
And it's going to be universal. There is
no way of escape.
So when it comes, you have to accept it.
The only halves
will be the government and the big
corporations.
Yes. The new feudal system as we have
said before.
And you will be
locked into that feudal system whether
you like it or not. And so eventually
you will own nothing and be happy.
Yeah.
A nearly identical version of the bill
has also been introduced in the Senate,
which means it is one step closer to
becoming law. Once passed,
the identity act would give the federal
government the legislative foundation it
needs to start providing a digital ID
service for American citizens.
This is not just America, this is
universal everywhere.
Yeah. As we have seen. So when the Bible
says that how many will be forced? All.
Both rich and poor.
Uh
Even though they say
it's aimed at the poor to help them.
There will no be no such thing as rich
and poor
um that have different
legislation. It will be the same for
both. All right. So they're saying it to
make things easier.
And of course they have to sell their
product.
But let's see what they say.
All right, Martin, that was a very
interesting little clip. Do you think
it's all only about clothes?
No, definitely not. Or is it to control
exactly where which item goes to and to
whom it goes? It shows you how far it
stretches. Even the clothes that you
wear,
you can rent and be happy.
You can rent and be happy.
Yes, and it's in conjunction with the
World Economic Forum, so it is according
to their pattern. And we've seen in the
previous one and many others that that
is linked to the United Nations. So as
you've said over and over, Now the World
Economic Forum,
all of those role players, are they all
linked to the Vatican? Yes. Are the the
corporations linked to the Vatican? Do
they have an accord with the Vatican, a
signed document with the Vatican? The
political leaders that are associated
with the World Economic Forum, have they
been with the Pope and received their
marching orders?
Yes. Why doesn't the world see this? I
don't know.
Huh? No, it's Why are they looking for
an Antichrist to come when the
Antichrist is alive and well and
performing his duties as per prophecy
right now? It's because they want to
hear cunningly devised fables. Uh-huh.
So the Canadian government is looking to
implement digital ID program despite
concerns of privacy experts.
Of course. Because the leader of that
country
is a blue-eyed boy of the World Economic
Forum
and therefore of the papacy. Oh, for
sure.
The COVID-19 pandemic highlighted the
need for government services to be
accessible and flexible in the digital
age. The next step in making services
more convenient to access is a federal
digital identity program integrated with
pre-existing provincial platforms, the
government stated. The net
is all pervasive.
A digital government puts people and
their needs first. How sweet of them.
It is accountable to its citizens and
shares information with them. It
involves them when making policies and
designing services. It values inclusion
and accessibility.
Martin, it takes away my privacy
completely.
I object to that.
It's for your own good. Oh oh yes, for
the common good.
Yes.
It designs services for the people who
need them, not for the organizations
that deliver them, the government says.
I call that sweet talk. Mhm.
Here's the UK government guidance on how
digital identity providers can become
certified to complete digital identity
checks for the right to work, right to
rent, and DBS schemes.
This development will align with the
disclosure and barring services proposal
to enable digital identity checking
within their criminal record checking
process.
Through the introduction of its identity
trust scheme. Now Martin,
if a government makes a law
and causes everyone to obey that law,
and you refuse to obey that law because
it clashes with your conscience and with
the Bible,
are you then a criminal?
Yes.
Because it's against the law. Uh-huh.
So that's the
digital identity system link you to the
criminal process. Definitely. So can you
be targeted? Of course. So then you are
going to be not even
um
an outcast, you're going to be a
criminal.
And you can be treated like a criminal.
And if you've got in your country
a death penalty for certain acts of
criminality,
it's not a problem for them to implement
it.
Correct.
This guidance sets how providers can
become certified to complete digital
identity checks for the right to work,
right to rent.
Uh won't you be able
Didn't the World Economic Forum say that
you would have to do all of those
things?
That's it. And that they said you'll be
happy.
But that's only if you adhere to them.
Only if you adhere to the principles.
Now how much is is your freedom
worth, Martin? Well, it's the son of
God's life.
All right. Now I've been working on this
freedom issue for a long long time in my
life.
The son of God, he will set you free,
doesn't doesn't it say so in the Bible?
And the Jews were highly upset and they
said we are slaves to no one.
But he said they were slaves.
He will set you free. Of course he's
talking about sin. Yeah. He'll set you
free from sin.
Uh that's that is another issue
altogether.
But it's more than sin.
So if you accept Christ, then you are
free indeed.
Right?
That means it is more than just being
free from sin.
It means a total freedom, but that
freedom comes at a price.
That freedom comes at the price of being
of one accord
with the system of government that God
has in place.
That's it.
Cognitive decision. So God has a series
of laws
which are the basis of his government
because without law you cannot have a
government.
That's it.
Now is God also a judge? Mhm. Mhm, yes.
Is he also an advocate? Yes.
Okay, but he only becomes your advocate
if you realize that you've lived in
transgression to his law. Is that right?
That's it. Then he will become your
advocate.
And he will defend your cause and say,
I've removed his filthy garment. I've
given him one that is in absolute
harmony with the precepts of
of God.
And therefore, if he embraces this
government
and makes it his own and
takes it to himself as a free gift
is entitled to be part of this
government.
Yeah.
But you are only free Mhm. in God's
government if you adhere to his
precepts. If you love me, keep my
commandments. He who says he loves me
and keeps not my commandments is a liar
and the truth is not in him.
And here are they that keep the
commandments that they may have the
right to the tree of life.
Yeah. Okay? So that's the precept. Now
the devil
is the counterfeit of God.
And he says, I have a system of
government.
And you
will have to be part of my government.
Which means you must adhere to my laws
and my precepts. And I will give you
free access to everything that you need.
He's doing exactly the same that God
does. And he did the same with Jesus in
the wilderness. Correct.
Everything that God does, he is doing.
And you will not be able to participate
in my world if you do not adhere to my
principles.
Does he say that?
Yes. All right.
So you are either a slave to
righteousness
or you are a slave
to this world and its precepts.
Either way, if you choose to obey God
you become a slave to his precepts. If
you choose to obey the devil, you become
a slave to his precepts.
So basically you're a slave both ways
round.
Mhm.
But Jesus says, if you accept his way
and his way of thinking he no longer
calls you a servant, he calls you a
brother. That's it.
Now Martin
if the two systems
are really
in terms of their essence identical
please don't misunderstand what I'm
saying.
If the two systems are identical, both
are based on law
and both are based on obedience to those
principles or else you cannot
participate in that world.
In God's world, you die and you don't
become part of it. You don't live in it.
In the devil's world, he will kill you
and you won't live in it. So you really
are between a rock and a hard place,
right?
What will determine
which one of the two
you will run with?
He's fair.
The one that you can choose.
Yeah, what will what will determine?
So if I have to now make a decision, I
have these two options.
I can be in the world
and participate in all that the world
has to offer
provided
I sign on the on the dotted line
that I will adhere to all of those
precepts.
And I have to do the same thing. I have
to sign a document which is called the
covenant
on the other side.
Now the only thing, it's like choosing
between political parties. I have to
look at the character
of the one and compare it with the
character of the other.
So I'm dealing with two lawgivers. Which
one am I going to run with?
The one that promises me
everything that the kingdoms of the
world have to offer and I'll be happy.
Or the one
that promised me eternal life on
condition that I come back into harmony
with his world.
Yes, and that you actually leave all
this the other one is giving you behind.
So I look at the two characters
and I see that this one
is based on coercion and selfish motives
and this one is based on love.
How do I know that this one is based on
love? Because greater love can have no
man that give his life for his for his
friend.
Okay? Now that's what Jesus did, didn't
he?
So Jesus was prepared to lay down his
life
so that
I could partake in all that heaven has
to have offer and be happy.
Now
in the devil's world, I will own nothing
and be happy.
Will I live in a house?
Yes. Okay. I will live in a house. Will
I have access to food? Yes. Yes. I will
have access to everything provided I
stick to his rules, right?
Uh who owns the house? He. He owns the
house.
Let's go to God.
Who owns everything that God has
created? He.
God created everything. He owns
everything. He says, I own the cattle on
a thousand hill.
Everything is mine. You own nothing.
He said, even the money that I give you
every month that you earn, I gave you
the capacity to earn it. It's my money.
Mhm. But I'll give you 9/10, you can use
it.
Pay me 1/10 back so that I can sustain
my system
and my ambassadors here on earth. Yeah.
All right? That's what God claims.
Now when he gives you a house one day
whose house is it? His. Is there any
difference between the two systems?
No.
There's no difference between the two
systems except the character of the
giver. That's it.
The one will use force and coercion and
kill you.
The other one
wants to give you life. And he loves
you. Yeah. And if you look at his
precepts, they're all logical Mhm.
and useful. Now, have you looked at any
government in the world statute
of law?
How thick a document is it?
That's I always say
they take the 10
10 away and then they have to have a
room full of laws to cover the 10. You
don't even know where you're going. You
put your foot anywhere and it might be
legal to put your foot there and you end
up in jail and you don't even know what
you did, right?
God, you know exactly where you're at.
So Martin, it boils down to the
character. Now
when God gives you something, he gives
you a house.
He says, I go to prepare a place for
you.
In my father's house are many mansions.
Now that irritates the devil. So in the
new translations, he gives you a room.
He says, be satisfied. I mean, he's
practiced that in his reductions in
communism. He gives you a room.
There's a room for you.
And even that irritates him. So in the
in the newer translations, he gives you
some space.
Not even a room.
So God says, I'll give you a mansion.
Now it's his mansion.
But when he gives it to you to live in
because he is 100% unselfish
how much of a ownership do you feel?
100%. All right. Because you will be
ruling with him.
Okay? Now when the devil gives it to you
isn't it with a sword over your head?
Yeah. You better. You better. All right.
So Martin, I've made my choice.
I'll run with God.
Because not only have I studied his
character, he has demonstrated his
character.
He is not one
that is not prepared to get his hands
dirty. In fact, he gave his life.
So all of this
is control.
Does God know
everything about you? Yes.
Does he know what you spend your money
on? Everything. Does he know how you got
it?
He's in the surveillance business.
His surveillance system is far superior
than anything that the devil can conjure
up with. Why why are we not angry with
God about that? Yeah.
Because he's not forcing you. Okay, let
me tell you when you are angry with God.
When you're doing wrong. Yeah.
Because you know you're being watched
and you don't like it.
Now, what if you can give that up
and your mind can come back into
harmony, then you will love God like you
love your neighbor. We've discussed
that, right?
Martin, would it be safe
in a world like that if I could read
your mind?
Yes. Wait. Is it safe in a world such as
we live now
if I could read your mind? Not at all.
Not at all.
All right, we'll leave that discussion
otherwise we could go on forever.
Bottom line what I want to say is when
it comes to the choice between the two
systems look at the character of the
lawgiver.
Here's another article from July 2022. A
handful of nations distributing new
digital ID documents.
So Vietnam, Brazil,
Saint Lucia, Greece, they're all
climbing onto this bandwagon. It is a
universal thing. When the Bible says all
He means. It means
all.
World Economic Forum publishes article
calling for global censorship using AI
and human intelligence.
This comes from August 2022.
I I'm very interested when I see this
man.
Uh he's very in tune with what the
Jesuits would love to do, right? He's
showing you what the plan is.
Did the Jesuits have a surveillance
system in the Middle Ages?
Yes, the Inquisition.
The Inquisition, right? They took it
over. Mhm.
And they did a fine job as far as they
were concerned because they murdered
millions of people. Did they go into
your house and do surveillance and
do everything that was necessary? Are
they doing the same thing even with
presidents in the world today?
Yes. Or ex-presidents?
Mhm. They're doing the same. And now
you've got the other side of this that's
people say, "Yes, but this is now the
portion that has to be wiped out. This
uh swamp has to be drained."
But Donald Trump embraces this man.
We've showed in the previous ones.
Even though it might seem that they will
that
these digital identities and all of this
will be still implemented and used.
They won't stop this now.
So, an opinion article published in the
World Economic Forum website has
proposed creating an artificial
intelligence program that could end up
acting as a comprehensive global
censorship tool.
Did the Jesuits and the papal system
implement censorship?
Yes.
The Bible. What happened if you had a
Bible
that was not approved by them or if you
had the book Table Talk by Martin Luther
as put together by his friend von
Amsdorf? I think you will be
getting hot under the collar.
No, Martin, you're quite wrong. Hot
above the collar.
Cuz they'll cut off your head.
Yes. If you're lucky. If you're lucky.
All right, we don't have to go into all
the details, but the extremism,
disinformation, hate speech, who
determines what is it extremism,
disinformation, and hate speech? They
do. They do.
Who's they?
Like I said before, we will never know.
But it's all these that are in
conglomerate with the beast.
All right, so behind it all sits that
beast system because that's what the
Bible says.
So, the proposed AI program would be
supplemented by off-platform human
intelligence gathering. Goldberger
stated, "We have a surveillance state
par excellence right here
with the digital means to implement it
on a global scale.
We have the Inquisition alive and well
and functioning
in Rome."
The solution to online abuse, AI plus
human intelligence.
And Martin, when the World Economic
Forum received a little bit of flak
because they want to become
like an inquisitorial organization,
they responded in this way.
"Please be aware that this article has
been shared on websites that routinely
misrepresent content and spread
misinformation. We ask you to note the
following.
The content of this article is the
opinion of the author, not the World
Economic Forum." Martin, if the World
Economic Forum places an article there
and gives it such prominence, doesn't
that mean that they
love this little article? If they really
wanted to s-
um put their money where their mouth is,
they should have said, "We do not agree
with this." Uh-huh.
"Please read the piece for yourself. The
forum is committed to publishing a wide
array of voices, and misrepresenting
content only diminishes open
conversation."
How nice of them.
Now,
there are politicians that actually
see through the ruse.
This is nothing other than a form of
implemented slavery.
We're going back to serfdom.
Let's have a look what Malcolm Roberts,
politician in Australia, has to say on
the issue.
Billionaire globalist corporations will
own everything. Homes, factories, farms,
cars, furniture.
And everyday citizens will rent what
they need
if their social credit score allows.
The plan of the Great Reset is that you
will die with nothing.
To pull off this evil plan, Klaus
Schwab's World Economic Forum will need
to take more than just material
possessions from Australians.
Senators in this very chamber
today who support the Great Reset
threaten our privacy, freedom, and
dignity.
Yes, they're in this Senate chamber.
Very soon, government will tell our
farmers what they can grow and punish
Australian consumers if they buy the
wrong things.
This has already started with
frightening reforms scheduled for
Australian agriculture.
The dream of micromanaging individual
carbon emissions hinges on the
soon-to-be-passed
so-called trusted digital identity bill.
It is only through the relentless
digital stalking of citizens that the
Liberal Nationals government can
micromanage purchasing choices.
Australian banks have already shown a
keen interest in the trusted digital
identity bill saying it will quote,
"Allow them to create a rich view of
their customers." These are the same
banks that already list climate risk as
a means to deny loans.
So, Martin,
we're not the only ones who are seeing
these things. Here's a politician who is
willing to state it publicly.
But uh he's barking up the wrong tree
because the Bible says it's going to
happen.
Yeah.
It's going to happen.
And that's where
I think some of the deception is also
coming in. Because like we've mentioned
before, if this
type of politician
doesn't link it to biblical prophecy,
then they as along with the preachers of
the false Protestant churches will be
the main leading figures in the
prosecution.
So, eventually
the devil is so clever that no matter
which side you come from, he's got you
trapped.
Yeah.
So, just to wrap this up,
Pope Francis authorized wiretapping
phones in financial scandal
investigation.
So, is this the sort of modus operandi
that the Vatican is quite happy to go
along with?
Yeah. And we can see in this article
what the power of the Pope is.
So, according to leaked documents
reportedly viewed by Sunday Times, Pope
Francis gave his permission for
investigators of the Vatican's Office of
the Promoter of Justice
to wiretap phones, intercept emails, and
even make arrests without the approval
of judges as part of their
investigation.
Isn't that what they did in the Middle
Ages?
100% We're back in the Inquisition. So,
have they changed their tune? Do they
have state power?
Correct? Because they ignored the
judges.
The New York Post pointed out that in
April 2021, Pope Francis amended Vatican
law to facilitate prosecutions for
cardinals and bishops.
Days later, the pontiff reportedly
ordered the adoption of technological
tools suitable for intercepting fixed
and mobile devices as well as any other
communication including electronic ones
according to the leaked documents.
"These powers may be exercised against
subjects whose communication activities
are considered useful for carrying out
the investigations."
The document state according to the
Times. This is the mindset
that we are dealing with here.
And
whether it is ethical or not, apparently
doesn't play any particular role. No,
because the common good card will be
played in this case as well. And there
are people that think it is quite quite
acceptable
to hack other people's data in order to
further their own ends.
In my opinion, it is totally unethical.
Absolutely unethical
because it is not love your neighbor as
thyself.
It is force thy neighbor
to do thy bidding. Yeah.
So,
the bottom line of our discussion is
is everything in place
Definitely.
when it comes to implementing the last
events described by the Bible?
We are right at the fulfillment of
prophecy. Okay. So, not only are we
at this combination point, but if we
look at all the issues,
the environmental issues,
the ethnic vision issues, the wars and
rumors of wars, the political issues
giving the power back to the beast, the
religious issues, the children returning
to the mother,
and the digital implementa-
implementation of a system to control
buying and selling,
and adherence to whatever they wish to
decree.
Is the table set? Yes.
Can the final
song begin.
We are on the verge of it. So, let's
pray.
Heavenly Father,
Bible prophecy is amazing.
And I thank you for it.
But above all things, I thank you for a
revelation of your character.
So, that we can make informed choices.
Help us to make the right ones in Jesus'
name. Amen.
Amen.